DON HARRISON: Hi, and
welcome, everyone.
My name is Don Harrison.
I am pleased to welcome
two authors in front of us
who are here to discuss their
book, "The Fourth Revolution,
The Global Race to
Reinvent the State."
On my far right is
John Micklethwait,
who is currently the editor
in chief of "The Economist."
Which one of you, in their
19th year, 20th year,
took a road trip across
the-- that was you?
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT: That was me.
DON HARRISON: That was you?
So I just wanted to highlight
that that was an important road
trip, which had a formative
sauna at the end of it,
with Milton Friedman.
Did that lay the ground
work for this book?
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT:
I should explain.
When I was aged 18 in
Britain, you take a gap year
before you go on to university.
And I came to California,
possibly quite a long time
before many of you here
were born, in 1980.
And I went to go and stay
with-- I was traveling around
with a friend, and I went to go
and stay with a cousin of his.
An elderly man called Antony.
And we stayed in his apartment
block in San Francisco.
And he persuaded
us to go and have
a sauna around the
corner with his neighbor,
a man called Milton.
And I sat there,
and Milton asked me
what I knew about
Margaret Thatcher.
Neither me nor my friend
really knew much about it.
And he kept on saying how
the world would change,
that British Rail
would be privatized,
that British Leyland,
this old car company,
would be broken up.
Margaret Thatcher would
introduce education vouchers.
That's something
called Monetarism.
And I was age 18,
19 at the time.
And I thought this man
was basically on drugs.
And I looked at
him, and I thought,
this is completely weird.
I've just come from Yorkshire,
part of Northern England,
and we had lessons by candle
light because of the miners
being on strike.
And later that week,
I went to go and watch
The Grateful Dead
play in San Francisco.
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE:
That's a rock band.
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT:
Nothing, nothing,
nothing that I saw
then seemed half
as hallucinogenic than what
I had heard in the sauna.
And yet, that was
Milton Friedman,
to my somewhat junior self.
And actually, in some ways,
it's a nice way into this book.
Because this book is an
attempt to say to people,
you may think that
government will never change.
But it can change very,
very dramatically.
And in fact, in terms
of the revolutions
we talk about in Western
government, what's
interesting about the
Milton Friedman revolution,
is we say the revolution of
Thatcher and Ronald Reagan
wasn't really a whole one.
It was just a half revolution.
And what we argue,
is that if you
think that you
should be despondent,
and you can see lots of people
who are going to troop off
to the mid-term
elections in November,
and if you think
of all the people
who are going off to
vote in Europe this week,
there's a sort of
despondent apathy there.
And what we argue in this book,
is that is completely wrong.
Is that all the
evidence of history
is that government will
change dramatically when it
needs to do so.
And the West has been through
three huge revolutions
like this.
But also, very
much to your world,
is that technology
changes things.
If all of you, and I
find this incredible
that anyone at Google
could think this,
but we do get this
reaction sometimes,
people tend to think that--
they seem to somehow assume
that all this change that has
happened to the private sector,
somehow won't happen
to the public sector.
And we argue that is
exactly the opposite.
Every huge revolution
government has been through,
technology has been
right to the core.
So that was a long way
segue from your sauna,
but that is the
message of this book.
That change is
coming to government
in a much, much bigger way
than people have thought,
but with one twist.
And that is that this time, you
are in competition with China.
And with Asia.
And with other places which
are working much harder
on government than the West is.
DON HARRISON: Great.
Well, I do appreciate that
you dove right in there.
At Google, we always like to
sort of dive right in too,
and sometimes throw
the PowerPoint away.
So I'll punch through the rest
of the introduction quickly,
and then we'll get on with it.
But I'd note that you
studied history at Oxford.
You had a productive
career as a banker.
That is close to my heart.
But then, unfortunately
became a journalist in 1987.
You were named Editor's
Editor of the British Society
of Magazine Editors in 2010.
And I assume both of you
guys are Friends of Google?
I've seen a picture in the book.
And notes that seemed
friendly in the text.
And on my immediate
right, Adrian Wooldridge,
who is the management
editor for "The Economist"
at writes the Schumpeter column.
Pronunciation OK?
Good.
And he was based in DC, where
you were Washington Bureau
Chief.
So let me-- I mean, you jumped
in and sort of explained
the basis of the book.
I want to say that my
impression of your book,
or what really stuck to
me, was a certain-- was
the call to action
that you describe.
You offer ideas, you
offer a clear roadmap.
But what I sort of
found interesting,
is both the history, but
also the clear engagement
you outlined.
You know, Mill, Webb,
Cromwell, Richelieu, Gladstone.
You know, all engaged, all
with a sense of mission.
We do have this apathy
towards democracy.
But you try to make us not
just despair about that.
And to provide examples
of how we move forward.
Was this-- you know, you
have a roadmap of action,
and then you also
have a call to action?
Are both part of the book?
Or is one more important
than the other?
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE:
Can I start off
by saying what the
revolutions were,
just to give people
a sense of why
we're saying that
there were revolutions.
Because we tend to
think, we can quite often
think that the State is
just something that's there.
Something that we can ignore.
And what we argue
very much in the book,
is that the State, has
for the past 500 years,
been a key to the
competitiveness
and the best of
success of the West,
and that the State has
constantly evolved.
And it's because it's
evolved that the West has
managed to stay ahead.
If you go back to
the year 1500, you
would find that
everybody in the world,
who wasn't completely
deranged, would
have thought that the future
of the world belonged to China.
China was much more
dynamic, it was much bigger,
it was a much more concentrated
civilization than Europe was.
China-- Europe had
three cities which
had more than 300,000
people as inhabitants.
The Heavenly City
in Peking alone,
had inhabitants of 300,000
people, many of whom
were civil servants
who were selected
by objective examinations.
The most sophisticated
examinations the world
had ever seen, from the
whole of the Empire,
to administer this great Empire.
So, Europe, by contrast,
looks like a sort
of blood-soaked battlefield.
A backwater.
Where you're constantly
fighting over religion,
you're constantly being
bullied by nobles,
who all have their
own private armies,
and are wandering around
in a rather lawless way.
And the way that
Europe gets ahead,
is first of all inventing, and
then reinventing the State.
The first thing Europe does is
invent the State as a security
State to provide public order.
That's the fundamental
thing that the State should
do, to have a public
order revolution, whereby
the nobles are
brought under control,
religion is brought under
the control of the State,
so you don't have any
dissent over religion.
So, public order,
but the same time,
a certain measure of
competition between all these
rather coherent Nation States.
They're competing
with each other.
In China, their system is so
big, the Empire is so big,
that it's very introverted.
It's very inward-looking.
When the Chinese
invented gunpowder,
they used it to
create fireworks.
Probably a nice thing to do.
We in Europe use it
to create weapons,
so to blow people
out of the water.
When the Chinese were confronted
with the possibility of trade
with the rest of the world, the
emperor in the mid 17th century
says, actually,
to all the people
who are on the coast,
the southern coast, which
is the most prosperous
part of the country.
You must move inland.
You mustn't mix
with those people.
It's an introverted
Middle Kingdom.
Europeans, on the
other hand, trade
with the rest of the world,
conquer the rest of the world,
create a dynamic, and rather
imperialist, obviously,
imperialistic civilization.
So Europe pulls ahead,
because of this invention
of the competitive
Nation States.
Then in the 18th
and 19th centuries,
you have a sort of
liberal revolution,
whereby you have a liberal
State, created as accountable,
that's efficient, and
that's much smaller.
So you have a contraction
in the size of the State.
Because the State
goes from being
a rate-seeking organization,
which basically deals
in sinecures, office
sinecures, to employees,
employs them for
doing nothing at all.
To saying, actually, we'll
select civil servants on merit.
We'll solve problems.
We will create a prison
system, a police system,
solve the basic problems of
an industrializing society.
So that's the
liberal revolution.
And then, in the
early 20th century,
because people begin
to complain that this
is a rather hard hearted
vision of the state.
They begin to complain
that the State needs
to do more to encourage
economic dynamism.
You get an expansion of
the role of the State.
Starting small,
starting with the notion
that the state should
provide a guaranteed
minimum of civilized life.
Education, welfare,
retirement payments.
But then the ambition
for the State
gets bigger and
bigger and bigger.
So, the Labor Party
in Britain, in 1945,
talks about building
a new Jerusalem.
Today's absolutely
the anniversary,
the 50th anniversary of Lyndon
Johnson's great society.
When he said, we must
create a great society,
and use the State get rid of
racism, get rid of poverty,
get rid of discrimination.
So, a more and more
expansionist view
of what the State could do.
But that vision, we think,
hits the buffers basically
in the 1970s, because of
over expansion of the State.
You get a reaction against
that under Reagan and Thatcher,
who say we've got to
contract the State a bit.
But that doesn't really work.
They did important things.
They got the state out
of running businesses,
like British Rail,
British Leyland,
which they shouldn't have been
running in the first place.
They got the industrial
relations much more
sorted out than they were.
But the state
continues to expand.
And what we're now
arguing, is that we're
at the beginning of a
fourth revolution, driven
by a number of forces, which
we'll talk about later.
But essentially, which
gives us a chance
to reinvent the State in
just as dramatic a way
as it was reinvented in the 16th
century, in the 19th century,
and then in the 20th century.
And we need to do that.
DON HARRISON: That's great.
So the--
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE:
Sorry, he fell asleep.
DON HARRISON: No, no.
I was trying to think if
I could relate that back
to the original question.
Do you think though,
that-- you know,
there was a great
quote in the book that
talked about-- it didn't
matter what system we had,
as long as it's
well administered.
Do believe that?
Do you actually
think that there's
qualities that allows
our systems to operate?
Or are there other
better systems?
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT: No, I
think at the heart of what
you are seeing now, is you have
seen a State, which has grown.
It has gotten far too big.
It tries to do too
many things, and you've
ended up with this
nightmare, where
both the Left and the
Right keep on adding to it.
Because the Left adds
hospitals and schools,
the Right adds prisons.
California is one of the
great examples of that.
And both sides keep
on asking for more,
and we've ended
up with regulation
in a complete sprawl.
One of the founders of the
welfare state was Sidney Webb.
Beatrice and Sidney Webb.
The first sort of Fabians.
He was the son-- his
mother was a hairdresser.
You now go to Florida,
and you discover
you need two years in order
to become a hairdresser.
To get a license to be
able to cut and blow dry.
Even Sidney Webb's
version of Leviathan
possibly didn't
stretch that far,
let alone the idea
you need two years
to become an interior designer.
And whatever vision
of the State,
if you look at John Stuart
Mill, Locke, Thomas Hobbes,
they never said the
State was set up
to prevent clashing
color schemes.
Perhaps a bit like these--
in your living room.
So there is a core to this.
There are two big things.
One, can you run
the state better?
There, we have
absolutely no doubt.
That should appeal to people
of any political persuasion.
It should appeal
particularly, actually,
to many of the
people in this room,
because there is a huge
amount of technology in that.
There is a whole variety
of things the State does,
which are completely
out of date,
which we can come back to.
But then there is also
an ideological question.
Because making the
State do all the things
that it does at the moment,
much better, is sort of obvious
and should be done much more
aggressively than it is.
But you also have
to go back and ask
these fundamental questions.
What is the State for?
And at least part of
the aim of this book,
or part of the pick
up of it, seems
to be that people, America,
Britain, and the West, who
have not thought about
political theory,
they have not thought
about what Mill said,
about what Hobbes said,
about what the Webbs said,
have come back to
ask those questions.
In a strange way, your have
Governor here, Jerry Brown, he
does actually think
about those things.
But time and again, when
people aren't thinking,
and our personal
answer is what we
would describe as a liberal one.
Is you have to take the
State's-- the burden
of the State off people, so in
order they can do much better.
But we think by doing
that, you could definitely
leave far more room to direct
programs towards the poor.
You could make the State
much more efficient.
So there are those two bits.
One is managerial.
Make the state work much better.
The second is ask yourself the
fundamental question, which
actually, politicians
don't at the moment,
is what is the State
fundamentally for?
DON HARRISON: So, talk about
then, about what forces
you think are coming to bear
that's creating an earning
crisis?
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: That are
creating the current crisis,
or creating the
opportunity for change?
DON HARRISON: Crisis is
always an opportunity.
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: Good.
I think what's the most
obvious thing that's
creating the current
crisis, is the fact
that we have an explosion
of entitlements,
of public spending, that
is really unsustainable.
That we-- you know, we have
the 2007 economic crisis.
And since then, we've pumped--
public debt has gone up
by-- I think McKinsey calculates
it's gone up by $13 trillion.
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT: 14.
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: $14 trillion,
that John is wrong, actually.
But before that, these
trillions were multiplying.
And what we have though,
the whole Keynesian notion
of the function of the State was
that the State should step in
at a time when private
sector demand declines.
A time when you get recession,
and potential depression.
And it should step in to
stimulate the economy.
Since 1960, America has
run surpluses five times.
Since 1975, France has
run surpluses three times.
No.
France has never run
a surplus since 1975.
And I think what you
have is a situation,
in what was once supposed to
be a crisis fighting mechanism,
has become something
that you do all the time.
Constantly stimulating the
economy, in a way that I think
is dangerous.
It's like constantly
taking steroids.
Constantly taking drugs
that stimulate you,
rather than taking them
to deal with an illness.
And this addiction to
debt is happening--
has happened at a time when the
age profile of the population
is getting worse.
You're getting
demographic change
that the population,
particularly in Europe,
is aging.
But also in America.
You have the retirement of
this huge baby boom generation.
So I think necessity
is driving a lot
of the reason for the
reinvention of the State.
Secondly, I think there
is a huge opportunity
to do things better.
If you look at the
State managerially,
it looks as though it's
in a different century
from the century
of-- even I work in.
Even I live in.
Let alone, you people at Google.
If you look at the school
calendar, it's 180 days.
America has one of the longest
summer holidays in the world.
During which time, I
think most school children
forget everything they learned.
And the reason for
that is so the children
could go and harvest the fields.
You know, it was an
agricultural calendar
created to free
children for harvesting.
Also, you have a lot
of industrial sort
of logic working in the State.
It's driven by the idea
that vertical integration,
the controlling and owning
everything that you do,
is the best way of
managing things.
Which is the way Henry Ford
thought about production
in the early 20th century.
It's not the way
the private sector
companies operate anymore.
So, managerially, there's a
lot of room for improvement--
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT:
I'll just come
in-- I'll just come
in and interrupt
there, very quickly, is that
one example we actually use
is this building.
We say, look at the difference
between Sloan's headquarters
at General Motors, back in the
1950s, these huge buildings
in the middle of Detroit, which
had the chairman at the top.
They had rows and rows
of people downstairs.
Now come to Google.
You see a complete change.
A devastating change in the way
in which companies organize.
The way that companies
have orientated.
Now go look at government.
Government has not
changed anything.
Sorry, didn't mean-- there
is a voice here saying,
clearly, we don't
understand Google.
It may be just as hierarchical,
and indeed, autocratic,
but it is at least down under
a veneer of communal action.
And that is perhaps the
way government should work.
But it is.
It is fundamentally different.
You don't have rows
and rows of people
where you advance by
seniority based on age.
But that is still the way that
the State fundamentally works.
So when Adrian is
saying it's out of date,
it's not just an
agricultural bit, a lot of it
is back in the Henry
Ford era, and a lot of it
is back in the 1950s.
And so merely,
we're not saying you
have to do anything
dramatically radical
just to bring it up
to the same levels.
But there are some
radical things
you can do to do
with technology.
And I've interrupted.
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: Well,
obviously, the other big prompt
is technological innovation.
And for me to talk to you people
about technological innovation,
would be rather like
me going to the 49ers
and talking to them
about football.
But I do think that we are at an
extraordinary time in history.
That in the 19th century, the
manufacturing revolution hugely
increased productivity.
And I think that you can have
exactly the same revolution,
you are having exactly
the same revolution,
in the service sector.
Whereby you can
increase productivity.
And the State is fundamentally
a service center occupation.
And one of the great
arguments about the State
has always been, you can't
really improve productivity
because it's so
dependant on human labor.
And there's a great economist
called William Baumol,
who invented the notion
of something called
"Baumol's disease," which is
essentially that productivity
in the public-- in the service
sector, cannot increase.
And his argument was that you--
to have Beethoven's string
quartet played when
Beethoven was alive,
you required four people.
To have it played now,
you require four people.
So you're absolutely stuck
with a productivity problem.
And I think that in one
sense, that's obviously true.
But in another more important
sense, it's not true.
Now you can listen to
Beethoven's string quartet,
you can listen to all
the music in the world,
virtually free, at an
incredible quality.
And I think that logic, the
logic of the digitalization
of information,
means that you can
begin to introduce the sort
of productivity improvements
that you've seen in
manufacturing, in the service
sector.
And that means
you're fundamentally
changing the nature
of the State,
fundamentally
removing a constraint
on the nature of the State
that you've seen before.
So I think that that is a
combination of the pressures,
the prodding from fiscal
and demographic things,
with the opportunity to do
things radically differently,
because of the nature of
information technology.
And finally, a third thing
is global competition.
I started off
talking about the way
that the State
has been dominated
by the West for
the last 500 years.
The West has been
the place where
all the big ideas and
innovations have come from.
And that has kept
the West ahead.
Now, you're seeing
something very new,
which is, lots and lots
of really good ideas
are coming from
the rest of world.
At a time when the
West is paralyzed,
I think, and rather
gridlocked and intellectually,
perhaps, ran out of steam.
Other parts of the world are
coming up with new ideas.
Brazil coming up the notion
of conditional cash transfers.
Which changes--
introduces incentives
into the welfare state.
The Indians coming up with
new ways of running hospitals
and getting medicine and
health care out to rural areas.
And above all, China coming
along and challenging
the two fundamental
ideas of the West.
The fundamental
ideas of the West
is that government should
be out of industry.
Should be out of business.
Well, they've invented this
notion of State capitalism,
and injecting government back
into the heart of business.
And the second idea is
that democracy works.
Democracy is essential
for circulating
elites, and that sort of thing.
And they say, no.
Actually, you can have a
top down, Mandarin style
circulation of elites.
So they're really going at
the very fundamental ideas
of the West, and saying, we've
got a new model, it's better.
History is being forged by us.
The West is left behind.
DON HARRISON: One
of the examples
you gave in the book that
actually resonated with me,
was the Khan Academy example.
It's a chance to-- you know,
we're seeing things like Uber,
and ridesharing.
You know, software
is allowing us
to sort of re-imagine
services that we've
taken for granted
for a long time.
The education one
is interesting.
You think we're at an inflection
point where we can see.
You know, productivity
gains, and things we've said,
you know, 20 students a teacher.
That can get much, much better.
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT:
I think that's true.
I think that you tend
to-- as you know better
than most people,
with the technology,
people tend to exaggerate
the short term gains.
But then, yet the
long term gains,
they underestimate
the long term gains.
And I think you can
see what's happening
in education beginning.
The Khan Academy is interesting.
Bill Gates, who I know is
a very popular man here,
he makes his children do their
homework with the Khan Academy.
That is something-- he's
the world's richest man,
but that is something
which is open to all of us.
And what is happening
in education
is making it possible
for star lecturers
to reach ever more people.
You're no longer just
wedded to the person
you have to listen to.
The talk and talk variety.
And yes, it's
going to take time.
And yes, you've got
these huge barriers
to do with the teacher's unions.
Because actually, what
we're talking about,
I said that the managerial
revolution is apolitical.
But actually, you
think about it,
it does pose really
substantial problems.
And I would argue it poses
substantial problems, possibly
slightly more for the
parties on the left,
and to use here the example
of the Democratic Party.
They are going to have
to make up their mind.
And you can see this with
Hillary at the moment,
really wrestling with this.
Is, does the Democratic
Party exist to try and help
the lot of the poor, or
does it exist in order
to protect the public
sector workers who
are it's absolute
core beneficiary.
Absolute core supporters.
Because if you believe any of
these things about education,
then that could be
amazingly good for the poor,
but much less good for
the teacher's unions.
Which as we know, are about
one out of 10 of the convention
members of the Democratic Party.
It's not just for the Left.
In this book we are
equally tough on the Right.
We think the Right Republicans
have two really huge problems
in trying to deal with this.
We see ourselves very much as
a sort of centrist manifesto.
A very radical manifesto,
but one aimed at the center.
The Republican problems are two.
The first is, they have got
to take the State seriously.
The most perfect example of the
Asian alternative is Singapore.
Virtually every single thing,
every single government service
that you compare America
and Singapore, Singapore
provides roughly two or
three times better service,
at usually about half the cost.
Little bit of that due to
authoritarianism, a huge amount
due to better management.
Singapore pays people at the
top $2 million a year to run it.
They do what any private
sector person would do.
They think there's a huge
problem running schools,
running your administration,
running your civil service.
If you do a good
job with that, we
will pay you a
huge sum of money.
At the moment, it's
inconceivable to imagine
any Republican senator
standing up and saying,
I think the civil servant
in charge of the Pentagon
should get paid $2 million.
Even if that man could save you
billions, they wouldn't do it.
So you have got to take
the State seriously.
At the moment, the
modern Republican Party
doesn't really seem to want to.
And the second
thing is, you have
to fess up, if you are the
conservative side of America,
to the real problem
of crony capitalism.
Because if you look at the way
in which you reduce the State,
the same way as Adrian
talked about the Victorians
in Britain reducing the State.
The Victorians in Britain
took a State 1815,
had 80 million pounds worth of
money coming in from taxation,
they reduced it to
60 million pounds
40 years later, at
a time when Britain
was the world's superpower.
At a time when their
population went up 50%.
At a time when
they added schools.
Off with all the other
things Adrian talked about.
And they did that by ripping
out crony capitalism.
Well, the crony capitalism
in America is a $1.6 trillion
worth of tax breaks.
Virtually all of which
goes to either rich,
or to crony companies.
And that side of
it, the Republicans
have got to deal with.
There is nothing in Milton
Friedman, that nice man
I shared the sauna with,
I was about to say shower.
But there is nothing
in him which says,
it's a brilliant idea to have
mortgage interest reduction.
So that more money
goes through that,
to the top 5% in America, than
goes through social housing
to the bottom 50%.
That is progressive
politics gone mad.
It is a tragedy that the
Democrats don't target that.
It's a tragedy the
Republicans don't
admit that that is big
government via another arena.
Look at all the money going
to agricultural industries
and so on, and so on, and so on.
Yes, managerialism can sound
sort of politically neutral,
but once you actually
start applying it,
it has quite big
political problems.
DON HARRISON: So I think, and
you touched on it quickly,
that in a book that I view
as extremely pro democratic,
you do spend a fair bit of
time talking about the virtues,
or some of the virtues
of the Asian systems.
Talk about the aspects that
you like in the experiments
you're seeing
occurring in the East,
and anything that
we could emulate.
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE:
I think the worst
sort of race to be
stuck in, in business,
is one in which you
don't know the virtues
and the competitive
strengths of your opponent.
And I think we are in a
sort of competitive race
with the Eastern world, with
the Chinese-centered world.
And the most foolish
thing we can do, possibly,
is to underestimate
their strengths.
So, I'm now going to
present a view that
is slightly optimistic,
or slightly praising
of their strengths,
in order that we
don't underestimate them.
But I think they've
done two things which
are really remarkable,
and we should think about.
One is that they've created a
sort of State capitalism, which
is very different from previous
forms of State capitalism.
It's not a form of
State capitalism
whereby they own companies, and
have them run by bureaucrats,
by administrators.
It's one in which they
own shares in companies.
They own-- it's sort of
equity based State capitalism.
And they have competitions
between various companies.
They set up constant
competitions
between telecoms companies,
between IT companies,
even if they're
normally State owned,
there's a lot of
competition going on.
And secondly, they've set up
a sort of top down autocracy,
which is very different from
other forms of autocracies.
Most autocracies die,
because the person in power
won't let go of power.
He's one guy, and
he's on the top.
And he gradually gets older,
and madder, and crazier,
and eventually disease, or
a revolution, or he dies.
What they do, is
that they basically
select this sort of
Mandarin style elites.
And they have their
job for 10 years.
And then they have a
peaceful transition of power
to the next generation.
So up until just before
Moody, the Chinese leadership
was significantly younger
than the Indian leadership.
That's why, in fact, India's
a democracy, and China is not.
So you have a
circulation elites,
you have competition between
State owned companies.
But at the same
time, the State is
acting as a sort
of guardian, trying
to think in the long term.
Now I can list,
and I'm sure John
will list, endless
qualifications about that.
The degree of corruption
there is, the degree of self
serving there is.
The degree of bureaucratization
of companies that there is.
But nevertheless,
there is a sort
of dynamism about
that system which
is really challenging the West.
And that has grown up,
that sort of dynamic,
sort of State
capitalism has grown up,
at a time when our own
version of democracy,
our own version of capitalism,
has got rather lazy.
Rather self indulgent,
and rather unattractive.
So if you look at the
period from 1945 to 2000,
roughly, democracy spreads.
The number of
democratic countries
relentlessly goes
up, and up, and up.
And when we reached 2000,
democracy stopped expanding.
Begins to go down a
little bit, but it's
basically static since then.
There are many reasons
for that, but one
is that China offers
an alternative which
is attractive.
And another is that
people look at the West.
They look at the European Union,
at its sort of huge, Brussels,
rolling bureaucracy, which
doesn't work very well.
Or they look at
America, its incapacity
to pass a budget, its
incapacity to run the roads,
invest in infrastructure.
Its incapacity to see schools.
And they don't see the shining
city on the hill anymore.
They see something
that doesn't work.
So the attractiveness
of the alternative model
is going up, while the
attractiveness of our model
is going down.
And why this matters, I
think, is that we actually
do want democracy and liberty to
win the great battle of ideas.
And if they are to
win that great battle,
they need to be much fitter,
and much more attractive
than they've become.
DON HARRISON: The--
I'm struck by the idea
that, I think it was six
years ago, seven years ago,
that China told all
its telecommunications
executives to essentially
switch governments.
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE:
That was fantastic.
DON HARRISON:
Switch country-- it
would be the same as Barack
Obama calling up and saying,
Mark Zuckerberg, you're going to
Google, Larry, you go to Apple,
uh, Tim, you're
going on Facebook.
Are there things
like that, that you
would like to see based on this?
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: I mean,
the story about this, John
will talk about this
a little bit more,
but the story about this
was quite extraordinary.
Because one of the guys who was
running one of the big telecom
companies was in Hong
Kong, and he was just
about to do a big deal.
And he got this call
in saying, you're not
running this company, you're
running the other company.
So he had to go in and sort
of renegotiate his position.
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT:
I love the idea
of switching people around.
And yet, I mean,
the example, China,
there are things right and
wrong about the government,
that-- the thing you
want to think about,
is that they are competing.
The thing we begin
this book with
is this place I've listed,
on the outskirts of Shanghai.
China Executive
Leadership Academy.
And it's a place where they
send all their people who
want to be ambassadors, who want
to run State owned companies.
And, you approach it, and
it looks a bit military,
there's barbed wire
on the outside.
And then you go in, and it
feels a bit like Harvard,
but Harvard as
redesigned by Dr. No.
Because--
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: ie Stanford.
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT: ie Stanford.
And you have a huge, red,
scarlet desk-shaped building
in the middle, and there's
an inkwell beside it.
And also dormitory
buildings around it.
And this is the place
they send people
to ask the question,
what works best?
Much less ideological
than other parts
of the Chinese leadership.
People get sent
there, and they are
trying to do the same as
they did with business.
The Chinese think,
well 25, 30 years ago,
we sent people to
Silicon Valley.
We sent people to the Midwest.
We sent people to Wall
Street and the city of London
to learn about capitalism,
and to gain information
to try and do things better.
We're going to do exactly
the same with government.
But there's one
really obvious twist,
is they send people Singapore.
They send people to Chile.
They send people to Scandinavia.
They send people,
yes, to some states.
They were sort of
rude about California,
but they've gotten slightly
more interested in it recently.
They're interested about things
that are happening in Chicago.
But they do not send
people to Washington.
They do not see-- all they
see is dysfunction there.
And that isn't just
an ideological bias,
it's also they're desperately
looking for things that work.
Even at a micro level.
And I think what
would be foolish,
is to discount, even
allowing for all of this,
because a lot of examples of
all the terrible things that
are going wrong in
Chinese government.
But they are really
working at this thing.
And we, to some extent, are in
the same position, just maybe
a slightly old version of it.
So I'm sure you could
probably think about it again.
It's like the
equivalent of kind of,
AOL sitting there, battling
against another search engine,
and not really thinking
about what Google was doing.
The worst form of contest.
Perhaps a slightly
better old world example
is Sears Roebuck sitting there
battling Montgomery Ward,
not realizing that
it was actually
in competition with Walmart,
and then with Amazon.
The worst competition
to be in is
one where you do not know
you're in the competition.
And that, I think,
if there's a big,
sort of message in this book,
it is that people have got
to understand, both in terms
of the opportunity, if America,
Britain, Europe, the West, takes
of this to defend democracy,
but also, actually , the threat.
Because there are other people
who are actually taking this
much more seriously than we are.
DON HARRISON: I'll turn it over
to the audience for questions
in a second.
But let me ask
one more question.
Talk about the role that
corporations play in this.
I mean, part of the growth
of the intermission economy
is that companies like Facebook,
like Google, Apple, Twitter,
can reach billions of people
almost simultaneously.
It's starting to play a role
in how legislatures act,
and how laws are viewed.
In your book, you sort
of allude to corporations
in the category of
special interests.
Do you-- you know, are we a
force of good, a force of harm?
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT: In obvious
ways, we're [INAUDIBLE] good
is.
For everyone at Google to
send out emails to people,
telling them to buy
this book, and thereby
engender the revolution
that we need.
But, I'll leave
Adrian to answer.
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: Well,
I think one-- ha, ha.
I think one way, one thing
we argue in this book,
is that corporations represent
a way of running things, which
government can learn from.
Their leaders, they're
more efficient.
They're more part of the 21st
century than government is.
But essentially, I don't-- I'm
not a person who believes that
all we need to do is
bring in Jeff Immelt,
put him on a commission,
and everything will be fine.
Because companies have
their own business to run,
they can't also concentrate
on running the government.
What I do think is
a fundamental thing,
is the purchaser provider split.
The notion that
the State actually
exists to make sure that
everybody has access
to education, or
access to health care,
or access to various
public services.
But in doing that,
it doesn't actually
have to employ the
people directly
to provide those services.
It can buy services from
a range of providers.
It might be internal
to the public sector.
Or might be external, and
encourage competition,
and bring in people
from all over the world,
public or private.
And I think a really
interesting example
of that is what happened in
Sweden in the early 1990s.
Sweden, the sort of example
everybody would think of,
of big government socialism.
And in the early 1990s,
they had a complete rethink
of the way they run their state,
and they decided, basically,
to encourage welfare
entrepreneurialism.
They basically said,
look, we believe
in providing free education.
We believe in providing
free health care.
But we don't believe
in providing jobs just
for the sake of providing
jobs to the public sector.
So they gave everybody
a school voucher.
Milton Friedman's great idea.
They allowed private
companies to run schools.
They allowed chains of private
They allowed private
companies to run hospitals.
Didn't say, you have to be
run by private companies,
they said, compete.
We'll give a contract to the
person who runs them best.
And that created
competition within schools.
It broke the power of
producer interests,
like teachers' unions, and
it spread good management
practice.
I went to a hospital
in Stockholm,
which was run by
actually, a private equity
company, on behalf
of the government.
And what you saw was that they
were introducing total quality
management, lean manufacturing,
all the sort of things
that doctors wouldn't
instinctively think about.
They were getting doctors who
were sort of Guild members,
almost, to work much more
creatively with nurses,
with other members of the staff,
because they were conceiving
their services as a whole.
And they also, when they created
this new management system,
they spread it around all
their other hospitals, all
around Europe.
So, good practice
spread around Europe.
So I think, it's not that we
want companies necessarily
to run things.
But we want to open the public
sector to competition, whereby
public private sector people
can compete with each other,
and the private sector can be
more like the public sector.
I mean, the other way around.
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT: Adrian's
hospital was free at the point.
So, free at the point of access.
So somebody who goes
there, it's free.
But behind it,
there is a company,
the contract is between the
government and the company.
DON HARRISON: Does
anyone want to ask
a question in the audience?
AUDIENCE: Um--
SPEAKER 1: Could you
hold on to the mike?
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
OK.
Google is one of the best
companies I've worked for.
And one of the reasons
is that it actually
uses engineering principles
in its management.
And that's really unusual.
I've worked at
Apple, I've worked
at a number of other places.
It's unusual for
management to say,
you know, let's do experiments,
and see what works.
Ben Goldacre has suggested
really interesting ideas
for your British
health care system.
Where they say, OK.
Well, let's do clinical
trials, let's find out
what's actually happening here.
And he's been quashed regularly
with truly sound ideas.
So, I'm curious
what you think first
of evidence-based
management, which
is what Google prides itself
on, and whether that's
something to do with it.
Because I haven't
read your book yet.
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT: OK.
I'll give you two
answers on that.
One, you are absolutely right.
There is a tendency within-- if
you look at the civil service,
and you put it alongside
the people in this room,
apart from the civil service
being somewhat older,
in pretty much every
country you would go to,
it's not a culture
at the moment which
rewards entrepreneurial
thinking.
If you're in the civil service,
it's the same pretty much.
It's amazing.
There are one or two
exceptions like Singapore,
but pretty much, if
you do like we've done,
and you travel around the
world, and you see people,
different government
offices, you
could tell within
about 10 seconds you're
in a government office,
not a private one.
And behind it, there
is a general feeling--
you've got a job for
life, in most cases.
And you've got a job for
life, unless you mess it up.
And so, it's almost exactly
the opposite culture
that you have here.
Here, you are here
to take risks,
to come up with new ideas.
So you're right.
And that's why the Goldacre
thing was squashed.
In terms of
evidence-based, I think
that is a really interesting
example about why people think
this is never going
to really take off.
But you look around
the world, what's
happening is experiments
are taking place.
Cities have to
start experimenting.
Mayors have got
to make-- chances.
And whenever people
say it's impossible,
just think of crime.
When I was younger,
you'd go to New York,
it was an absolute nightmare.
Look at every single
number to do with crime.
It's gone down.
Largely because people have
worked out how to do it.
And that was very much
started in the cities,
with Giuliani and [INAUDIBLE]
and other people like that.
Look at the way that
people are trying things
at the provincial level.
Even Google, I
think, helps things
within the District of Columbia.
There's various things.
There's also experiments
going on at the bottom.
And the other
crucial thing, which
is where the Goldacre thing
comes in, is information.
Because we talked
about education.
Yes, there's always
ways in which
technology is helping education.
But the most
radical way, is it's
telling you how bad
your schools are.
You're all in California,
you now know your schools are
massively worse than Finland's.
You've known that for the
past four or five years.
The PISA test.
The most recent
PISA tests tell you.
They're not just worse than
Finland's, they're worse than
Poland's.
So you are paying more
money to get worse results.
And the more that information
starts going around,
you can see it in things
like Facebook groups.
You can see it in things like
websites which are devoted.
And that is very much a
kind of bottom up revolution
which is going to
push this, I think.
And you can see again,
Adrian mentioned Sweden.
Another thing Sweden does
is, every hospital has
to publish all its results
online, so you can see.
So again, it's about
the internet just
gradually working, is a way
to police the public sector.
So you don't-- yes, maybe
the changes we talk about,
maybe the Bloomberg presidency
came in, then maybe you would
see a wide range of these
things going through.
Maybe there is a
Thatcher, or someone
like that, who will
push this through.
But there is also just
the massive evidence
in front of people of how
things can change at the bottom.
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: Well,
we talked a great deal
in this book about
the paralysis that
is characteristic in Washington,
and the fact that America
really is not the sort of
beacon that it once was.
On the other hand,
America, because it
is this federal system, because
you have so much initiative
on the part of the
states and cities,
has also got lots and lots
of great things going on.
It just doesn't quite
come together at the top.
It's hard to scale up
these things, really.
AUDIENCE: So you seem to suggest
that the technology is going
to help things out, because
competition would increase,
transparency would increase.
And at the same time,
if you think of people
as sometimes being foolish and
inaccurate, and easy to believe
false beliefs, you
can you imagine
that charlatans, for
example, could take hold
and false beliefs could happen.
And I wonder, what are
the limits for this?
So if we think about the
FDA, for example, in the US,
which is clearly a very
bureaucratic organization.
And let's say we
just cancelled it,
and we let people just create
whatever medications they would
want.
I suspect we would get
much more fake medicine
that would cost
people lots of money,
and would kill people
much, much faster.
So, I'm wondering, where
is this belief coming from?
And is there any evidence that
openness and transparency's
always going to lead
to better outcomes.
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT: That's
a terrible example.
I think that it's obvious nobody
wants to get rid of the FDA.
I mean, there's a big
difference between wanting
to get rid of-- the FDA is doing
something transparently useful,
and it helps.
It helps markets, it
helps a whole variety
of different things.
There are some things-- I
know there are criticisms
about some bits of
things the FDA does do,
and it is useful to some extent,
that there's more information
out there, so the FDA
can be held to account.
What we're saying
is, keep the FDA,
get rid of the
rules that say you
need to spend two years
training to be a hairdresser.
Because I don't-- although I
would worry about what kind
of food you are getting, I'm
not too worried about who cuts
your hair, although
it looks very good.
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: I mean, let
me give you an example of why I
think you're-- always is the
problem with your-- I remember,
I lived in Washington,
in the early 2000s.
From 2000 to 2010.
And during that
period, there was
a-- the public school
system doesn't work.
And there's was
a lot of pressure
to introduce a voucher
system, and to introduce
charter schools.
And you would have
parents, black, poor,
impoverished parents, who would
be queueing up outside schools
to try and get their
children into those schools.
Because they knew those
schools were better.
Now, these people weren't
making foolish decisions.
They were making decisions
absolutely well informed.
Because they knew the schools
that their children were
trapped in were
useless, and they
knew these schools provided
a better education.
So in many, many areas
of the public sector,
the people who really knew--
people, ordinary people,
are very well equipped
to make decisions.
You don't need to have
an expert tell you.
And in fact, the expert
is going to come out
with a much worse decision.
I think it's one
of the worst things
that Obama has ever done,
was to send his own children
to a private school,
Sidwell Friends,
whilst denying ordinary black
children within Washington
to be able to make
a choice themselves.
So my prejudice is that
choice is quite a good thing
to give to people.
Not to choose to legalize
drugs that kill people,
but to choose where they send
their children to school,
to choose what sort of public
services they get from utility
companies, and things like that.
I think it adds a
dynamism to the system,
and empowers parents.
AUDIENCE: So, I'd ask you
if you have any evidence.
Is there any
evidence that there's
a domain life in which giving
people free choice is better?
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: Yes,
I just gave you evidence.
AUDIENCE: No, no.
This was a story about your
own experience in Washington.
Is it not?
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: It's
considered evidence by me.
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT:
There's a lot of-- guys,
there's a lot of evidence
about if you give people
more choice in
things like schools,
you can go-- you've got
socialist examples, like we
gave you Sweden, as one example.
You can go look at that.
Look at the example
of education.
There's a lot on it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great.
Sorry about that.
Basically, my
question is about how
to increase political will
to do some of these changes.
Because obviously, you guys
have written a book in order
to start a movement,
or maybe continue one.
Call it something more concrete.
But my question is, it seems
like we've had the information
revolution for a long time.
And that hasn't been enough.
And it seems like you have
to deal with a system that
currently exists
that would be opposed
to a lot of these measures.
How do you actually get these
changes to manifest themselves?
Because I've heard some
arguments about-- well,
at least from your talk,
I haven't read your book,
something along the
lines of, oh, you
know, democracy
might be threatened,
you know, kind of like,
if aliens attacked,
humanity unites.
But in this-- I don't-- that's
one way to potentially create
will to make some
of these changes.
But I think that
there's huge obstacles.
So, how do you think you
can actually make some--
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT: I think
some of them, as I said,
is a variety of people
seeing things happen.
If you live in San
Francisco, and you
see that LA has a
much better system,
you're going to start
militating to get it.
That's certainly what
happened in crime,
is that people saw what
happened in New York,
and they wanted more of
the same thing elsewhere.
It made a big difference.
There's also-- and I'm
saying that there is now
more information.
So that's the general argument.
It could be-- as
you say, it could
be specific leaders
arise to pull it.
But I think what
is worth noting,
is a lot of the problems
of the American State
aren't actually that dramatic.
I mean, the one which everyone
talks about is entitlements.
But you look at the
Simpson Bowles Commission,
they set off-- a group
of wise men so to speak,
they set off to go look at it.
They came back roughly
with the same answer
as pretty much
everyone has, which
is, you have to push
out the retirement age.
You have to put up
the retirement age.
You have to push it up
towards 70 slightly quicker.
You have to do the
same with Medicare.
You have to do some
fairly basic things.
You have to do this-- tax reform
is just sort of bleedingly
obvious.
We've given you, you know,
America has quite high taxes,
particularly in corporations.
But then it has all these
ridiculous exemptions,
which just require huge
amounts of form filling.
And there is a
sort of deal where
you come through,
where you tax reform,
you do entitlement reform,
and actually, the basic budget
begins to look much better.
If Barack Obama had taken on
Simpson Bowles and said yes,
I think that would have
been a huge jump forward.
A massive jump forward.
And actually, it's-- I
think when Obama comes to be
considered by historians,
and certainly when Obama is
considered by himself, I
think in 10, 15 years time,
when people are talking
about the Obama/Bush,
the Bush/Obama years of splurge,
where there was no attempt
to really bring this
problem under control,
I think people will actually--
Obama will actually seriously
regret that.
It was, I think a
catastrophic decision,
both in terms of American
government in the long term,
but also actually, probably in
terms of the Democrat Party.
Because it was a fantastic
way to skewer the Republicans.
Because suddenly they were
hoisted on their own petard.
As a--
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: I think it's
a great question you asked.
But I do think that the speed
and the impact of the IT
revolution has really begun
to sort of change very
dramatically.
Particularly the way
that you can possibly
introduce-- you can use IT
to educate people, I think.
That you can-- there's
a sort of a vividness
now of lecturers over the years.
But I do think that it's not
something that is automatically
going to come because
of technological change,
or just because people think
that you can manage things
better.
We do argue that you also have
to add a new ingredient to it,
which is ideas.
If you look back at all of
these great revolutions,
they've partly taken place
because some group of people
begin to argue that the State
should be doing something
very differently.
I think the 19th century
revolution of John Stuart
Mill and the philosophical
radicals in Britain
was driven by a group
of people saying,
what should the state do?
It shouldn't be providing jobs
for aristocrats and sinecures,
but for people that should
be solving these problems.
It should be organized along
meritocratic, accountable
lines.
And the one ingredient
which we really
think that you need to
throw into this, which
means that the problem can't
just be solved by Google,
and can't just be
solved by McKinsey,
is a big philosophical question.
What should the state be doing,
and what shouldn't it be doing?
AUDIENCE: The columnist that I
first read the term [INAUDIBLE]
and together with [INAUDIBLE],
it has stopped being fallacy.
That information technology is
destroying white collar jobs
faster than it creates new ones.
You might agree or disagree,
but it's very clear
that a lot of people
in San Francisco
agree there's a very strong
anti-technology sentiment
out there right now
in San Francisco,
and the country as a whole.
And a lot of the fight of income
distribution ties into this.
People feel that they
are losing ground,
and it seems to me that this
is a very difficult problem.
If you address
this problem, this
might reduce the
velocity of the West
compared to autocratic
countries, who, I mean,
are quite happy to
have inequalities.
What have you thought of this?
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT: A very
interesting question.
Again, I think you
have this phenomenon.
I agree that we all think--
we had a cover on it.
We all think that the
speed of the technology
is going to rip
through services.
I put this again to the lady
who's in the same situation
as I perhaps was with Milton
Friedman in the sauna.
Not imagining how much
these things could happen.
You all find it
very easy to imagine
it happening to
the private sector.
It will happen to
the public sector
even more, because it
is patently overmanned.
Productivity in
the public sector
has been so low, compared
to the private sector.
I think you twist it both ways.
If you take one of the
great insights of economics,
a profound statement by
a man called Herb Stein,
one of the great
economists, said,
if something cannot go
on forever, it will stop.
You apply that to
inequality, all the people,
I wonder, around
the world, seeing
in Europe and America,
Asian even a bit,
inequality, for a world leader,
is now becoming, usually,
your second biggest problem.
It's either inequality
or fairness.
And the problem is even
as economic struggles
to do with it, we all
know what economies
have to do to do about
inequality, it takes time.
So from a political viewpoint,
you have this huge pull
to the left, I think,
in terms of people
thinking about redistribution.
You have kind of Piketty
as one example of that.
On the other hand, the
other side of this,
is the space that
we're talking about,
which is the other thing
which cannot go on forever,
is the ever
increasing government.
The one thing that's
been consistent
in every single
person in this room,
is that we've all lived
in an age where government
has gradually gotten bigger, and
bigger, and bigger, and bigger.
And I think that is something
that cannot go on forever.
So if you can unleash
productivity through that,
you could also do
enormous amounts of good.
So on the one hand,
you have, I suppose
that is a pull
slightly to the right,
to start thinking
about different ways
of dissembling government.
Now, the pull from the left,
in terms of inequality,
is another direction.
So, you're right.
It's a huge thing.
This plays into it,
but it also provides,
I think, new twists within it.
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: I think that
it's a very profound question.
And I think it's one of the most
difficult issues of our time.
And as somebody who writes a
column named after Schumpeter,
who talked about
creative destruction,
I think it may well be
the case that there'll
be some people who want more
destruction than creation
in the future.
But on the other hand,
these very forces
that are changing the
occupational structure also
create new ways of
teaching people.
New ways of training people.
New efficiencies in
transmitting knowledge.
So, many of these people who
were losing their jobs, who
have seen their jobs displaced.
On the other hand, the
positive side of that,
is that they can probably
be constructive in new jobs
in much more efficient,
much more up to date ways.
And I think that there
was an interesting example
of a course that
was recently taken,
and it was created to train auto
workers in Detroit to IT jobs.
And this had been
basically run by the city.
It had been run very badly, and
had an incredibly low success
rate.
And it was taken
over by Infosys,
which has got an incredible
internal training system.
They take people who are
bright, but not completely
ready to [INAUDIBLE] jobs,
and push them up to a level
where they can take this job,
and it had massive improvements
in the sort of results you have.
So the very forces or the
challenge you get also perhaps
contained the solutions
to our problems.
DON HARRISON: Guys, we're
running out of time.
I'm going to ask a general
question of you guys.
We've had a bit of a
rough month in Europe.
We have a hard to understand
decision by a European court,
on right to be forgotten,
we have the publishers
rising up, and trying
to use anti-trust
as a cudgel to beat us down.
You know, just a couple
other examples, as well.
What do you-- first of all,
what do you think of us?
And then secondly, how do
we-- how do we fix it right?
JOHN MICKLETHWAIT: Well, no, no.
No, no.
No, we have a
tentative back view
of quite a lot of
anti-trust things.
The one angle where I
personally am slightly--
I'm nervous about, is
the issue of privacy.
Or privacy, as some people say.
I'm one of those
people who have begun
to rethink exactly where I
want the sort of parameters
to be set.
But on the whole,
I want somebody--
I want somebody who
will have the default
settings for privacy
set relatively high,
so people start from that angle.
And I do think there
is an element whereby
I think at Google,
it's the fate you have.
I think that many previous
technology companies before,
where this will become
I think, that big.
For better or worse, a
great part of your life.
I think the dangerous
thing about what
is happening in
Europe, is that there
is a profound misunderstanding
of how entrepreneurship works.
And that comes
through repeatedly.
Another one dwells
with the people
who are making these decisions.
And it's not just a question
of Google and Facebook.
It's more basic than that.
You look at the
companies that make up
the more dynamic part
of America, many of you
barely existed, even
a few years ago.
You have the
equivalent in Europe,
it's a tiny proportion of that.
And so, yes, there
are individual issues
where privacy, as I
said, is one where
I'm beginning to get more
interested from actually
exactly the liberal viewpoint
that we champion in this book.
So if you think that
is a vital fact,
you can't just buy John
Stuart Mill or Adam
Smith on economics,
and ignore it
when it comes to
individual liberty as well.
But overall, I
think that there is
a kind of slightly
worrying attitude,
especially from the Europeans,
about this inability
to understand exactly
how a commercial--
ADRIAN WOOLDRIDGE: 30 of
the top 100 companies,
of the biggest 100
companies in California
were founded since 1970.
The figure in Sweden,
which we'd rather lauded,
in terms of its public
sector management is 2.
DON HARRISON: Well, thank
you very much for coming in.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]